You're here along with the rest of us to
speed the entropic death of this planet
to service the chaos
we're maggots eating a corpse
what's wrong with you
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this is going to be my
Westworld season 3 episode 6 video if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos careful
for spoilers if you have not seen the
episode obviously we'll do top 10
and Easter eggs as we go along starting
with number 10 the title of the episode
was decoherence usually that term
applies to quantum decoherence which is
kind of like a loss of coherence in the
quantum state of particles but in the
episode it's a metaphor for just the
chaos that erupts through the world is
also a very apt metaphor for what's
going on with the men and blacks mental
state as well as Maeve's plans Dolores
in the Charlotte version of Dolores as
plants is everything kind of spins into
chaos so number 9 the intro the episode
picks up with mabe experiencing her
original memory with her daughter in the
park the one that she kept remembering
during the first two seasons she wakes
up in a new dress in a copy of the field
that Serac has created a special
environment saying that I can give this
to you you can have this paradise it can
be real he waxes about the nature of
memories how human memory is imperfect
but because she's a host she remembers
everything perfectly she's not taking
any of his bull crap but she does ask
for some backup which he is happy to
oblige while also threatening her life
again pretty much every conversation
that they have every time that they talk
he always reminds her that she's
expendable they have a bit of a funny
moment when she wakes back up in the
Warworld Park again only this time she
has all of her abilities to control
other hosts inside this simulation and
she sort of uses it as a catharsis just
working her way through the soldiers to
clear her mind a bit of a therapy
session which is a nice parallel for the
man in black storyline when he goes
through his multiple of different
therapy sessions so number eight the man
in Black's first therapy session this
one is real it's happening in the real
world there are a couple points in the
episode when you're made to question
what's real what's fake
then they reveal at the end of the
episode that some of it was fake but
this first one is still real so these
are just other people in the mental
institution where Dolores stuck him he
waxes about the nature of God giving his
argument against God if there ever was
one Humanity is terrible we must use
everything he doesn't care about us
anymore he makes more metaphors about
whom
seeming like the villain in all this in
hastening the world's demise the number
7 things start to spiral out of control
even more the therapist tries to get him
to talk about his daughter he seemingly
owns up to it I know what I did I don't
need to be in here because I understand
exactly what happened it's my fault I'm
the one that killed my daughter she sets
him up for the ar therapy then things
completely spiral out of control for her
in the background if it wasn't totally
clear why her life seemingly got flushed
down the toilet just in the span of time
that she was having that conversation
with the man in black I think that's all
to do with the insight profiles that got
sent to everyone there was probably
something on her record somebody found
something out about her backstory that's
why she probably lost her license and
whatever was also on there was so
terrible that her husband is like please
never contact us I'm taking the children
later in the episode as he walks by you
see her hanging herself but this is also
at the point when he's seemingly drugged
up so you made a question what's real
what's not real I think she really did
wind up killing herself Bernardin's
stubs show up at the end of the episode
implying that everybody just went so
crazy that nobody cares about him or
they forgot about him so what kind of
implies that this level of craziness is
happening all over this mental
institution but number 6 that crazy a
our therapy session I think they did a
good job of explaining it before you
start to see all those visions so it was
pretty clear what was happening they
have a way of hooking him up so he sort
of walks through his memories
re-experiencing things but it's all
implied to be very traumatic because he
sees a younger version of himself
reading that book you hear an abusive
sounding father out in the hallway
yelling at his mother by the end of the
episode you find out that his past is a
little more complicated than you were
led to believe but there's all about the
question of whether or not he was
destined to do all these things or if
there's a result of all the choices that
he made
either way the point is is that he
clearly has a history of violence the
number-5 charlotte Dolores with
Charlotte's family this is the version
of Dolores who's getting confused about
who she really is
her personality the Dolores personality
is bleeding together with the memories
of Charlotte Hale they try to use her
husband is the voice of reason during
the episode sort of like the voice of
the audience like hey you know the
machine doesn't have to decide your
future it's within our control we decide
what we do you also probably saw the
Easter Egg in the background as she's
walking through the crowds of variety
people you see them graffitiing the maze
on the wall there next to her house and
it's a little bit like the maze from the
first couple seasons on the show like
all these humans in planet Earth are
breaking their loops quote-unquote like
Dolores one of them too because they got
their insight data they have a funny way
of answering that storyline with the man
in blacks storyline at the end of the
episode but this Charlotte version of
Dolores seems like she's caught between
both Serac in the main version of
Dolores like she kind of realizes that
the main version of Dolores is really
only using her she's expendable and she
even tries to talk Charlotte out of
helping her family they're not really
your family but Charlotte still feels
like they are because the memories have
all bled together Syrah comes kills the
board member in broad daylight saying
that it's no big deal because it's so
chaotic outside but nobody notices then
later arrives the deal is done you see
all the logos all over Della's start
switching to insight remember he's only
here because he wants the backup data
for the human copies so that he can give
it to Rehoboam to perfect its algorithms
the number for Serac orders everyone to
destroy all the data at Delos he only
wants the backup copies for Rehoboam
burn everything else trillions of
dollars worth of IP doesn't care at all
about it it's important to know that
Charlotte is able to make the backup
copy and send it to the other server so
there is a backup copy of all the data
but as the board convenes he outs her in
front of all them remember this is all
about things spiraling into chaos so no
surprise that Charlotte then pulls a
fast one on them again killing the other
board members escaping love that they
brought back that giant robot you kind
of wondered what they were going to do with
it when they teased it earlier this
season like oh I could probably find
something for you to do and she does as
it Hulk's out helping her escape
probably one of the best parts of the
episode though number three the man and
blacks all man and black therapy session
you could kind of see the direction this
was going when the camera panned up and
he was like oh crap what the hell is
going on here
there's a big clue that this was all
happening inside his mind or inside this
AR therapy session is it the guard that
comes to pick him up to take him to the
therapy session is one of the hosts from
Westworld he recognizes him and says
wait a minute you look familiar
sometimes it's kind of hard to tell in
Westworld what's real and what's fake
sometimes they'll go into
the cinematic aspect ratio and sometimes
it'll be sixteen by nine usually that's
how you can tell when you're inside a
system but usually they only do that
cinematic aspect ratio for the West
world Park systems where the hosts
backups are stored the way they're
playing it with the man in black is
really weird like it sounds like he
might be some sort of weird hybrid
between human and host it all has
something to do with that irregularity
on his blood when they were putting him
in the AR machine it detects an anomaly
this Iraq later references when he's
talking about testing all the other
executives at Delos to find out who the
copy is right now I'm still leaning
towards the man in black being real and
other people are just messing with them
remember there's a lot of Technology a
lot of biotechnology to make you feel
like you're experiencing things that
aren't really happening so even though
it gets really wild and really trippy
with his storylines as to what's real
and what's fake I still think that he's
real right now and that's the whole
point is that he kind of starts out with
this really tragic backstory that the
James delos copy makes fun of during the
therapy session are you lying about your
backstory
but then grows up to be a successful
executive seems like he's going to have
a happy life then things just completely
go to hell when he goes to the
west-world part falls in love with
Delores he slowly winds up becoming the
man in black seeming like a villain of
the story and now seems like more of an
antihero like he says he's going to save
the world
they also dosed him with that blood
tracker so that's also probably part of
the blood abnormality that they pick up
when they're testing him putting him in
that AR machine so number two you have a
standoff between Maeve in the copy of
Dolores that Serac created trying to get
the key from her they're still trying to
get that back up on the satellite of all
that host data as well as the human
backups they do this really cool thing
where all these different versions of
Dolores even though they don't
necessarily know exactly what the other
copies are doing because they're of the
same mind they're from the same source
they have a pretty good idea and they're
able to surmise exactly what's happening
so she proceeds to tell Maeve oh I would
probably have a back-up plan for this it
Charlotte goes to kill Hector you see
Maeve sort of lash out in rage you see
all the lights in the real world start
to dim out remember she has this
connection to the real world so she can
see what's going on outside the
simulation - she's able to make it out
into the real world but there's also the
second host that got printed - we don't
find out who that is I'm wondering if
then taking a page out of Dolores's book
and just printing a second copy of Maeve
to make her twice as powerful the number
one Serac kills Charlotte's family just
as the man in black finishes killing all
the versions of himself you could kind
of sense where this was headed midway
through the conversation all the
different versions talking to themselves
it's sort of different aspects of his
mind so as he says he kind of narrates
the action later if it wasn't totally
clear I'm killing all the past versions
of myself everything I've done it
doesn't matter anymore
it only matters what I'm going to do as
charlotte dolores crawls out she looks
kind of sad but she's still alive she
still has the backup so I'm wondering if
she's going to be seeking revenge for
what happened to Charlotte's family I
love the way that Serac talks about her
too the reason why we found out that you
were the copy is because you cared way
more about Charlotte's family than the
real Charlotte Everwood she would have
never called her family in a crisis like
this that is cold but while that's
happening you also have the man in black
sort of capping off the lesson of the
episode all this chaos what's real
what's fake was I always destined to
become this crazy person that I am today
or is it a result of all the actions and
the choices that I made turns out
doesn't matter that feels like the
writers talking to us in a meta way that
it doesn't actually matter whether or
not he's a host or if he's real but you
guys can let me know in the comments
after the episode do you feel like he's
real or do you think that he is a host
they imply in the trailer for next
week's episode that we're going to get more
into Caleb's backstory there's a lot
going on in the flashbacks that he was
experiencing during his trip in last
week's episode this sort of confused his
timeline like he doesn't totally
remember what actually happened or
somehow his memories have been altered
remember there are only two episodes
left they're only eight episodes this
season so my episode 7 video will post
next week everyone click here for all my
Westworld episodes and click here for my
brand new guardians of the galaxy 3
video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe I'll see you guys tonight!